the relevant page number and paragraph
number
sorry it's working now i was using the
wrong
the wrong keyboard
oh thank you chairman we're ready to go
thank you welcome to rockford district
council's remote
meeting of the audit committee and
welcome to anyone watching this
via the live stream
i'll start with the gender one apologies
for absence
we have none in the office are there any
other apologies
no
um counsellor stanley's indicating
chairman
councillor stanley thank you chairman
uh james dupout will not be attending i
shall be in his place
thank you that is for uh gender item two
substitute members so
okay we move on to that a gender item
two
councillor stanley in place of
councillor newport are there any others
your hands still up counselor stanley
thank you
agenda item three non-members attending
um you will read out any non-members
attending
okay counselor counselors fd
and williams chairman
thank you very much agenda item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of november
2020
are these agreed members
i will assume so unless anyone clicks on
the raised hand icon
and chair if i may just say something
there
yes please um i just wanted to bring
some members attention that we
um agreed at the last meeting that we
would bring a report
back in relation to the redmond review
recommendations
and we've agreed to defer that until the
next audit committee meeting so there's
no
no report on that on tonight's agenda
but that will be brought to the next
meeting thank you
thank you naomi
all right agenda item 5
to receive declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
right all right before we go on to the
rest of the
um evening's work we have debbie hansen
from ey who is presenting item eight
rather than her sit through the whole of
the evening because she has other things
to do
would everybody agree that we move item
eight to the next
item are you agreed
are you doing that emotionally yes
chairman anyone disagree
it's true
let me see if anyone does anyone
disagree with that
sorry chairman i did ask if it no it
doesn't look like it
chairman i think that council ahoy is
saying sorry councillor
i can't hear you i think it yeah i don't
know why
my hand isn't moving but it was moving
and i said um
i assume this is a formal motion as
required i didn't hear who seconded it
that was all
i've got no problem with it i just
didn't didn't hear who seconded the
motion
um that's america i believe
chairman i think that councillor mrs
shaw has seconded that for you
all right thank you yeah okay i thought
council america
i was just about to journey so is that a
grade everybody
agreed agreed agreed agreed
read
sorry my interrupt chairman i thought we
had a protocol thank you
um chair my head hand was up and it's
come down again
i i was i understood there was a
protocol for
agreeing things again i've got no
problem with agreeing to this i thought
agreement was on the protocol that we've
agreed agreement was
agreed and someone if someone disagreed
they put their hand up
i thought that would happen you didn't
have a hand up
i think you misunderstand me i don't
know if my sound is playing up tonight
or not
what i meant was i understood according
to the protocol for voting
i'm perfectly happy with agreeing
something but i understood that we only
had
had to demonstrate non-agreement
otherwise we were taking
to agree it so we agree unless we put
our hand up
is that correct i don't know if it's
worth confirming that with sonia that's
all
chairman that is correct um agreement is
assumed unless somebody raises their
hand
whether by the blue hand or manually if
that's not working for them
and i don't believe anybody's hand was
up
no there aren't any hands up chairman
all right in that case then i will go
straight into item eight
which is the external audit indicative
audit plan
debbie hansen from the council's
external auditors
ew will introduce the report
questions can be asked and answered
afterwards thank you
you chair and thank you very much for
accommodating by moving
the timing of the item it's much
appreciated because i've just come off
another audit committee so
um i'll be able to go and get something
to eat after this um
so this is our indicative audit plan the
reason it's indicative as we haven't yet
um undertaken all of our detailed
planning for the 2021 audit
however based on the discussions we've
had we've had with officers
based on our knowledge of the client
from working with you for a number of
years now and based on a wider knowledge
of the sector
we're comfortable that we can um do a
reasonable plan which has what we think
should be the key risks that we need to
address in our audit
there is one area of work that we
haven't really been able to do much
planning on and that's about value for
money conclusion and i'll explain that
in a little bit more detail in a moment
what i'd like to do is really take the
committee members through section one of
the report which is the overview of our
audit strategy
so that starts on page seven of your
pack
and read that just highlights the key
risks that we've identified in
doing the planning that we've done to
date and the details of those risks and
how they've changed from prior year
the members of the committee will see
from looking at those that actually
there is
no real change in the risk that we've
identified for 2021
compared to the prior year but i will
just take you very briefly through those
risks
so the first one we identify is
misstatements due to fraud and error
that's a risk that includes is included
in all of our audit plans and it's
driven by auditing standards
and we have a set of procedures that we
undertake to address that risk
linked very much that risk we then also
identify the incorrect capitalization of
revenue expenditure
and we again we always identify that in
local authorities that have any sort of
material levels of capital spend
and that's because that's a mechanism of
getting expenditure
out of revenue and hitting council tax
and into the balance sheet which can
then be funded by capital reserves as
opposed to revenue items
we then highlight and we move on to the
areas which are are kind of inherent
risks so they're not our significant
risk but
still areas of focus for us and the
valuation of london buildings again
would always be an inherent risk it's an
extremely large balance in the council's
accounts
and is an estimate that's based on
information provided by the council's
valuers
i think one positive thing for for
rochford is that
if you had a material level of
investment properties we would be
identifying that as a significant risk
because
of the impact that kobig 19 has had on
that type of assets which are valued by
reference to the markets
but we're comfortable that based on the
makeup of your the london buildings the
council owns that we don't have a
significant risk in that area
if we then move over page we have a
pension liability evaluation which again
very similar to ppe is a very big number
and based on estimates and assumptions
and so we engage our internal pension
specialist to provide us with some
assurance around that
area and then finally we have going
concerned disclosures um this was a new
area that we reported on last year
in terms of increased focus which was
driven by two things
it was driven by the impact of kobe 19
on
not just local authorities but the whole
whole economy and the uncertainty that
that brought
but also changes in the auditing
standards which required auditors to
give greater focus to going concern
assessments
so again that's an area we'll be
continuing to focus on in the current
year
on the next slide we just highlight you
materiality we've set that at the same
level
as previous years which is two percent
and then we've set materiality
performance materiality apologies at 75
which is the maximum level we can set
and that recognizes i think the the
significant improvements in the accounts
that we've seen
in the last couple of years with very
low level of errors coming through those
which enables us to set that at a higher
level
if i could then just take members to
page 19 of the report
which sets out value for money so that's
section three
i really just wanted to highlight to you
because this is something that has
changed this year
the nao brought in a new code from the
first of april 2020
so that applies to the 2021 financial
year
and that makes some um sort of fairly
large changes actually to the work we do
around value for money
one of the main changes of the
previously we would have included in our
audit report
a conclusion on value for money and
that's an overall conclusion
we no longer do that so we report purely
by exception
in the audit report on value for money
so we would only include comment in the
audit report if we were qualifying your
value from any conclusion
we also don't provide an overall
commentary anymore instead we are
required to provide commentary
on the three specified reporting
criteria which are set out on that slide
so that's financial sustainability
governance arrangements
and then improving economy efficiency
and effectiveness
so that's quite a big change and what we
require to report on that in a new
form of audit report called the
auditor's annual report reports
which normally would be issued the same
time as the audit opinion
but the nao are looking at putting in a
slightly later date this year to
recognize the
continuing pressures of covid on
auditors and local authorities so we may
be reporting that
later in terms of the detail reporting
on that area
so i think i think those are probably
the the main changes what it does mean
is that previously if we hadn't
identified a significant value for money
risk we would include very little
in our reports to that effect we would
just say we haven't identified a risk
but now we need to include commentary on
each of those areas
whether we have identified a risk or not
so that will drive more audit work
and drive the need to engage more with
the council around
that new requirement so that was really
the main thing i wanted to draw to your
attention i'm very happy however to take
any
comments on anything in the report or
any questions
um councillor lucas gill
thank you chair uh debbie you mentioned
uh council valuers
for uh council property i assume these
are
external by the years uh employed
or appointed by the council is that
correct that's correct yeah the council
uses a firm called wilkes head and eve
to undertake their evaluations and so we
undertake procedures to make sure we can
rely on our work and if necessary we
engage our own internal valuers to
review any more challenging or more
difficult assets that we may come across
thank you
uh councillor sparing uh
thank you chairman debbie i i don't know
if it comes under your
your remit but obviously and it's not a
it's just a question um obviously the
the councils had to pay out
lots of grants etc this year or sorry
in 2020 uh under review
do you does it come under your remit to
monitor the way they've been
paid and and the the integrity of the
way it's been paid
i i have to say i've had no reason to
question this i'm just asking the
question
it would be an area that we'll be
looking at this year because as you say
there's there's a number of grants that
have been received by the council some
of which are to support the council
in its own spending so for example the
the grants to
to recompense the council for loss of
income um which all councils have
received
um there are other grants that the
council has received which you very much
been passporting and acting as an agent
for us so that's payments to local
businesses that have come through the
council
but wouldn't be reflected in the
council's accounts so the areas that
we'll be looking at are those areas that
are reflected in your income and
expenditure
as part of that we will obviously as
part of interrogating your lecture we
will see those in and out transactions
so we will
be ensuring that they have been
correctly excluded or correctly treated
in the financial statements
but in terms of checking that those
payments are being made appropriately to
businesses or anything all the
controls around those that wouldn't
really fall within our remit and i'm not
sure whether naomi might want to
to comment on on that area but we
wouldn't be
checking that the council has been
implying applying the sort of controls
and checks before paying out grants
which you're acting as an agent for
thank you um
yeah i suppose just add that there are a
number of controls in place that um
mhclg and other government agencies have
um checks and balances open in place to
make sure that we are paying out
grants to businesses appropriately so
there is quite high level of scrutiny
around
um around that and quite a a number of
reporting requirements for us back to
government so
so there are yet there are a number of
controls to make sure that those are
being done appropriately
sorry can i just add something um yes um
internal audience has been doing some um
sample checking
of business grants paid out to
businesses so internal audit has done a
number of work in that area so we have
been checking payments yeah to make sure
they're valid
fine thank you very much and cancer
sparing are you happy with that
yeah no i say i had i wasn't being nasty
about it
cancer sparing i didn't hear your answer
i assume um
counselor stanley next please
hello chairman yes um could i just ask
the question
is in the uh audit um with the
health and safety side of things um is
there any
uh arrangements now that or
since kovid that uh arrangements
that the the officers are not working
from the office
or offices of rdc
and working away
in in their own homes and they obviously
would have to travel backwards and
forwards is that health and safety part
being adjusted to suit
um if if i just jump in there if i may
share
um i think there's obviously some wider
risks
and um sort of uh issues to consider as
part of them
changes as a result of kobe but i don't
think that that's something that would
fall under the remit of the external
audit
um plan but we could maybe pick that up
if you've got specific concerns when we
um look at the internal audit reports
we've got later on in
the agenda if you've got any specific
concerns
okay thank you
hey i can't see anybody else wanting to
ask a question is there anybody
can you see anybody's sonia no no one's
indicating chairman
chair sorry to keep jumping in i may
just say a word as well
um in terms of the covering report for
this um
for the um external audit for this year
and i just wanted to draw members
attention to the change in the reporting
deadlines that government have agreed
and that passed through legislation this
week so
um the previous deadlines for preparing
the accounts were
um 31st of may um
with a with a deadline for the audit to
to be completed by the end of
july if possible and they have agreed um
for this year and for next financial
year that there will be a two-month
extension to those deadlines so
um the date for our accounts to be
um completed would be the end of july
and to be audited by the end of
september although
members will note from the audit plan
that's put forward we are intending to
have the accounts
prepared by the end of may so that the
audit can commence um
in in june in line with um ey's plan
um but yeah debbie i don't know if you
wanted to just add anything more about
that
no i think as you say we we are looking
to schedule our audits over a longer
period and actually we are not planning
to complete all of our audits by the end
of september because that's just not
going to be possible so our phasing
actually runs to december
um but the proposal we have at the
moment is that rockford is one of our
earlier transfer of audits
um and so hopefully that works in terms
of discussions we've had with the
finance team about that fitting with
your timetable as well
and obviously enables us to hopefully
get the audit out of the way quickly and
efficiently
but as i said we are scheduling all of
our audits over a longer period just
because of the
the capacity and to actually be able to
do the audits properly
um we need a longer period than than
currently in the legislation
yeah yes thank you um debbie hansen for
that because uh
i'm pleased to hear that we are going to
be one of the first because we we did
ask
um that we could get our audit done you
know in a timely
manner this year so thank you for
reassuring us of that
so there's no further questions
you've got a recommendation
on page 8.2
is that the annual audit plan and
addendum from 2021
20 21 be noted
is that agreed
chairman i think for clarity numbers
i think is that noted members i think
chairman for clarity if members could
just
um uh you know we will assume agreement
unless uh unless members raise their
hand
please
councillor merrick are you able to raise
your hand
yes i am now um chairman yes
you weren't early i was just checking
thank you for that
right thank you very much um debbie
hansen for
uh your presentation and uh you are
welcome to stay but i think you need to
get away now don't you
thank you very much and that's again
it's really appreciated moving the
agenda around
thank you thank you very much bye-bye
right members we now return to
item six the audit progress report
twenty twenty to twenty one
uh mike paul to the council's chief
audit executive resources will introduce
the report
thank you very much chairman um if i can
direct members to
6.4 of this agenda item
um one of the things i'll start by
saying is that 2021
has not been a normal or typical year
for um
undertaking internal audio work um
working remotely has brought a number of
problems
um i suppose the normal audio approaches
we
we want to um establish a rapport with
the audit clients
and that's that's quite easy with
face-to-face contact so you go and sit
with the audit client at their desk
you discuss the audit area under review
you ask a number of questions
they readily provide the evidence in
terms of
the the information you want in terms of
your testing
so it all works quite nicely as i say
working remotely brought a number of
problems now we have to
sit up in my meetings we have to
basically
put all our questions in emails and wait
for a response
um sometimes that response is not
forthcoming immediately so we have to
try again
so working remotely has brought a number
of problems for us as internal auditors
um what was also hoped this year in
terms of
an assistant gym and delivering the
audit plan it was hoped in quarter four
so january to um march of this year that
my audit team would assist jim
in delivering the audit plan for 2021.
what's
happened is that um due to incompatible
it
um frameworks and id systems we've not
been able to use our it
kit to log on to the the rockford portal
so
jin's been left to deliver the audit
plan alone unfortunately
um that said we've now gone through a
process at basin and rolling out new it
kit
so going forward we should be able to
support jim and delivering the audit
plan
and next year's audit plan um that said
i mean jim's been working really really
hard over the last nine
nine 12 months and as you can see from
6.4
1.2 he's delivered a further six audit
engagements
since november um three of those
were rated as adequate two as good as
one is limited
um the limited audit review was related
to tourist management and perhaps up
past the gym now he
might want to say a few words about that
audit
jim i think you're on mute
apologies chairman members forgot about
that bit
uh if i draw your attention to the
audit page 6.11 which is the report
on risk management um
basically we've given it as a limited
assessment
not so much that the controls are not
there
is that there's no real evidence of
anybody physically looking
at them to make sure they're being kept
up to date
we've had a major changes in the working
structure this year
people work from home and there's no and
everybody has addressed the
issues of working from home and nobody's
actually documenting it
to see if we've got any gaps that can be
dealt with and during our testing
uh it would stick it was very obvious
that the half-yearly
reviews of the risk registers uh were
not done
um i'd like to just sort of bring
attention to the last
paragraph here that um
there's supposed to be there was a
supposed to have been a
in update of full service area risk
registers
in january uh under a new format
as it stands at the moment still only 16
of 29 risk references have been updated
and so there is no reason for us to
change the assessment going into this
annual general state
annual government statement as
that current position
thank you thanks jim
okay uh come come back to to the plan
item itself
as i said earlier with um with limited
resources available what we've had to do
is
essentially um re-prioritize the audit
plan and look at actually
what audits we need to undertake to
enabling me to provide
an opinion at year end so it provided
enclosure to
is this is a list of the last year's
audit plan
and what audits we have undertaken and
which audits we are yet to complete so
this gives a full picture
of those audits we will complete this
year
and that will enable me to provide my
opinion
and the council's arrangements for
governance risk management
internal control so the audit plan
itself is a mixture of like i suppose
must do audits we must do those in order
to provide an annual opinion
and those more of a consultancy nature i
suppose nice to do all this
something that the service management
said can we take a look at this
but it doesn't necessarily materially
alter my opinion
at year end if i can move on to counter
fraud activity
one of the things we have been doing is
supporting the
refs and ben section in terms of the
examination of business grants paid out
so what we've done done is undertaken a
sample checking
of the business grants that paid out and
we haven't found any um
issues or concerns in relation to the
business grants paid out
nothing to suggest that fraud's thoughts
happened
um in relation to counter fraud um the
senior compliance officer has been
undertaking quite a lot of work in the
area of fraud
and has generated significant savings
for the council particularly around um
council tax and um unbuilt properties
and as we can see
as reported on 6.4 2.2 he's achieved 112
000 pounds worth of savings i suppose
the only the other thing to know
in relation to count fraud activity the
senior compliance officer based on reps
and benz
has been recognized nationally and has
um
been given an award in relation to to
his work in relation to
um counter fraud
so just moving on to the last era of my
report and that's
in relation to internal audit
recommendations we only have um
eight current live recommendations um
three of those in terms of the due date
have been pushed back
but we accept that um managers may have
other priorities
only to covered so um implementing audit
recommendations may not be top of their
list of things to do
but we accept that and we are working
with them to implement those
recommendations
um since november um reports committee
we've only um issued one one further
recommendation
i'm quite happy to take any comments or
questions in relation to that report
any questions members
council hire councillor high
sorry chairman it took me a while to get
my mute unmuted
um just a very quick one on page
6.1 five i think
i'm dashing one screen and it can be a
bit awkward getting to the right place
um yeah six point one five
um no 6.14
we're referring to the um final
paragraph on page 6.14
where we did an email
phishing exercise and 10
of the staff emailed opened a link on an
external email
um i'm quite concerned that was so high
and i'm quite concerned that
that that doesn't have seen
see much action beyond reminding them of
their responsibilities
and asking them to do additional
training i think
we do have a number of staff joining and
leaving
um on a regular basis and i just wonder
if
this is really an adequate response
to quite a high level of people opening
their email eight
emails in this way opening attachments
on emails
chair do you want me to oh sorry mike i
was just gonna
quickly say something there if that's
okay yeah certainly
um yeah as i i'm the kind of council's
senior
information risk officer um and
um i do um accept your concerns
council why about about the um about
that fishing exercise and i do work
closely with them
the council's i.t manager and she um
has rolled out a number of initiatives
to try and um
improve the um kind of response to these
kind of exercises and as you
referred to that we have had some
specific training recently right
run by um a member of the police who
who came in and and provided some
awareness training
and um in addition to that um the
leadership team including myself have
followed up specifically with
individuals um who who did open the
email
to to make them aware of of the issue so
it is something we take seriously and
are following up
proactively um to continue to raise
awareness and
i think that's probably the biggest
thing we can do is just continually keep
this impression people's
minds and make them aware of the risk um
as i say to continue to train people on
that risk
um but yeah mike i don't know if you
wanted to add anything further to that
oh yeah we have run um similar exercises
better than council
and ten percent is probably about the
norm it's it's about education and
training there will always be those of
people
who just click and don't think about the
ramifications
or what the content the email is but it
is it's just about training training and
training
and then carrying out further exercise
to determine whether the
the percentage rates actually comes down
and then and then educating it's all
about education and training
it's little more you can do to be honest
all right thank you sounds um yeah from
the report it sounded like you weren't
doing as much as you are doing
so that's fine thank you
yeah thank you uh
councillor stanley thank you chairman
uh just a quick uh quick question really
um
just how much of the audit is still to
be
finalized uh i understand from mike that
the some some of the older is not being
completed
obviously how can we sign off the audit
if it hasn't been completed
when will it be completed does he does
he think
okay yeah all those audits necessary for
me to provide
an opinion year-end will be completed
before my annual report so basically
uh by about uh april all those audits
will be completed so
there's audits that i need to complete
or need to have completed to provide
that opinion
there are some audits as um identified
in closure number two
that we are deferring until next year so
we won't take undertake those until next
year
but they're not important in terms of me
providing an overall opinion year-end
so the key pieces of work will be done
by year-end
those are the ones that will enable me
to provide my opinion
and as i said earlier there are certain
types of audits that those
there's audits that must be done or i
say you must be done to give that
opinion and there's those audits that
it won't matter what the result that
what it is it won't affect my overall
opinion on the council's arrangements of
governance
risk management or internal control so
coming back to come back to it it's
basically we will do
all the necessary work required to
enable me to provide an opinion
that then feeds into the annual
government statement there won't be
anything
not done to provide that opinion
okay thank you is it is that what what
fur [ __ ]
it's a risk-based audit plan all the
audits that are
highlighted is significant risk will be
undertaken
may i add something here please chairman
sorry was that someone speaking there's
a gym from the
team may i have a point here
yeah yes please thank you um it's just
uh
since we put the uh all its reports to
uh
to finalize um two further
key audits have been having completed
and i anticipate another two financial
financial ones being completed early
next week so we're making trying to make
progress on what we consider to be the
important ones
thank you thank you very much
so much um is that answered your
question
cancer stanley yes thank you very much
um councillor sparing thank you chairman
mike you you mentioned that uh basildon
are rolling out some
improved or different i.t so that we are
more compatible with each other
let's hope we never have to go into
another lockdown but
you know we can't just just totally
disregard that anymore i'm afraid
and will this mean that
the compatibility and the working
relationship
will considerably improve and the things
that you've
pushed over to to next year will be able
to be accommodated with because of the
new closer
interface between the i t systems
yes well i can do i can give you
assurance that will be the case because
i've taken um delivery of my new it
equipment
last week and i'm currently using that
and i've been
able to access the rockstroke portal
over the last few weeks
so what we're doing is now rolling out
to the rest of my team and just checking
actually
they can sign on to the portal it's it's
all down to security
both sides for some reason there's some
incompatibility in relation to the
security settings and
so it's i suppose it's it's over secure
in a way
because i can i could always get onto
the um
sorry portal using my own personal
laptop well that's not considered
um secure enough and because because of
the increased security arrangements
um suppose works laptops if you'd like
to put it we can't
sign on to the rockford portal but if i
use my old
you know stone age personal laptop i can
get onto the russian portal
so i think it's basically we've been
over cautious in terms of
rit security and therefore they don't
talk to one another
but be unfortunately unlike rocha who
rolled out their new it kit
prior to lockdown someone must have had
a crystal ball at rockford i don't know
how it happened
but
someone was getting paid lots of money
and was rubbing their crystal ball
because those very clever
so rocha took delivery of a new it kit
prior to lockdown but us at bazillion
have been working on
rubbish for the last 12 months but we
are now going through a complete roll
out of it kit
so yep going forward things will be back
to normal
thanks mike
thank you councillor lucas gill
thank you chair a couple of months ago i
received
an email supposedly from the iit
department
telling me i needed to change my
password
i did check with it and they said no
it hasn't come from them but i do
believe
some members actually went through and
changed their password
um has that affected our security
and i don't know if councillor fd would
like to come in on this
i i can't comment because i'm not aware
that specific incidents or how that has
progressed i don't know whether naomi or
jim can comment on that
uh chairman the uh ex
funny enough the uh fishing exercises
where we had the ten percent of staff
picking
was based around changing of uh
passwords
but um there was enough in there to sort
of say it wasn't from us
but people did open it and this is where
the education element continues to
become
important i think council lucas skill if
i may i think we might need to just
check the it department because i'm not
sure if members were actually part of
that fishing exercise or whether that
was a genuine kind of
scam attempt but i think i don't think
any of us here have the details of that
so i think we'll have to come back to
you separately on that if that's okay
yeah i did speak to the it department
before i did anything and they confirmed
that it wasn't from them
so i deleted the email straight away
okay thank you yeah man i think uh that
um
dong tribe uh notified all councillors
that it was a it was a fishing and and
also a scam exercise that was going on
um and it wasn't an exercise from rdc
and to take no notes of it
i think we all had emails to to that
effect
yes i think councillor stanley i
remember something of that of that
um sort with the an email coming from
dawn tribe
uh i can't yeah we've had no
dangerous effect from that with the
council i.t system
um well i think all we can say cancer
girl is that um
like a skill sorry and say well
i'll double check with the i.t
department but i think i would be aware
if there had been a genuine kind of um
yeah i.t security breach that affected
members so i i don't believe there is an
issue of that nature that has been
um affected members so i i will double
check that for you outside the meeting
okay thank you
all right i can't see anybody else
wanting to ask any further questions
um what i would like to say is uh
uh to mike porter's well done on the uh
member of staff getting the award
and uh thank you jim for all your hard
work
um with what you've been doing as well
so members at paragraph 9.1 on page 6.2
there are
three recommendations which are all for
noting
one that the update on delivering the 20
20
21 audit plan b noted which is enclosure
one
two that the conclusions and results
from completed audit engagements
in appendices two and three be noted
and three that the updated status of
audit recommendations in appendix 4 be
noted
is that noted members if not can you
raise your blue hand please
a chairman that's noted
all right thank you i
item seven that is the audit plan and
charter
for 2021-2022
mike paul to chief audit executive will
introduce the report
um what i'll start by saying we've not
included the charter um i've had a quick
look at the charter and there's no
changes from last year
so we're not bringing it to members for
this year as there are no changes to be
made um
in terms of the audit plan itself
the audit plan is essentially a
programmer work for the new year
and sets out the audits we are looking
to undertake
during the course of 2122. the audit
plan itself is structured around
the council's corporate risks um i
suppose one of the things is
i suppose it links to the previous item
in terms of delivery audit plan so as
we're learning from
our mistakes so in terms of this year's
audit plan or
the audit plan for the new year we're
not setting out
all the audits we could undertake
because the audit plan
is essentially a leaving um
document in itself it can change subject
to new and emerging risks
so rather than set up all the audits we
were thinking about all the audits we
could possibly deliver
knowing they may change we'll put
setting in the plan at the moment
all the key areas we need to undertake
for that audit opinion i referred to
earlier
so at the moment the audit plan is the
key areas we're going to undertake some
work on the musts
at some point in time we may add to the
audit plan in terms of those other areas
we may want to look at
but at the moment we're not setting out
our stall
for the whole year this is because it's
a living document the audit plan
it may be subject to change these are
the key audits we must undertake
for that annual opinion year end so
as i said it looks at the corporate
risks facing the councils
and we consult with the senior
management in terms of actually
what audits they might want to put in
the audit plan
i do some horizon scanning in terms of
what are the new emerging issues facing
the internal audit what are the key
areas we need to look at
i suppose a bit like external audit what
are the risks now facing the council
what are the council's key objectives
and priorities for the new year
and that's how we come up with the audit
plan
i'm quite happy to take any questions
around the order plan
counselor michael hi
uh thank you chairman
this is fun um i suppose it's the same
question every every
year really i seem to ask this question
and i do wonder if any if there's going
to be a year when we actually do have a
full
internal audit staffing available to us
um i
i i take on board what you're saying
that you're you're happy in that
you can or we can perform internal
audits over the areas which
are the highest risk um and again when
you look at the
the plan you've said it's not complete
there'll be more things to add on there
and as it's a living document and it
does look
quite full however that does give me
concerns that we've been doing this net
now for quite a few years we always we
never seem to be
have the staff to do anything beyond the
most important areas
which is fine i understand the most
important areas but that
that does mean that there's going to be
some areas presumably which have
not been looked at for some time because
we're looking at the high risk areas
is that a cause for concern or not
i would say probably not of course
concern because all audit plans put
forward by most likely authorities are
risk based
so if it's not a high risk then it's not
not an issue it's not going to give you
any concern
you don't need to look at it because the
ramifications are not looking at are
pretty quite low
so you're going to look at the areas
that might cause problems or
lead to issues in the future so those
areas that you don't look at
probably once every three years no
they're not of course can concern
because
it's not going to cause you financial
loss or reputational damage to the
council
so you could ask why do i need to look
at it it's not going to create a
financial loss
it's not an i.t issue it's it's not
reputational damage
i know it might be some of those surface
improvements
or efficiencies you could put forward as
recommendations
but beyond i suppose surface
improvements and efficiencies in
practice
no there's not a lot else there are no
control weaknesses to be identified
so in reality it's there's something
that's both in the way the service
department itself could look at
they could look at its own operationals
um
in-house and go well i need to improve
these areas it doesn't necessarily
need an audit so you could uh they could
undertake
a form of self-assessment if you like so
internal audit is about
looking at those high risk areas and um
doing those audits um i suppose
on the plus side um becky will be coming
back from may
um to so we will be back up to the two
auditors
and as i said earlier now we've got it
we can hopefully support jim in
delivering the audit plan
um i suppose lack of resources and
staffing
is a national issue even in the big
audit firms are struggling to get staff
in to deliver those external audits
and internal audit is similar we are
struggling
to get high quality auditors they're not
out there anymore
and the ones that are out there you're
gonna have to pay a premium to get them
um we could buy in audit days from from
some of those companies
but like off like it audits are in the
region for a thousand pounds a day
so you're not going to get many days um
for your money
um i think normal audit work is around
750 pound per day
so again buying it in um
it does cause some problems in terms of
you know do you have the money to pay
for it
but i think we we are still able to
deliver those key audits necessary for
my opinion
so i'm quite happy
okay thank you on that basis then where
we have requests from
management for for an internal audit to
look at certain areas such as
the vehicle maintenance for instance is
that really
a job for internal audit then or as you
say should that be more of a
service review internally yeah i mean
we we do audit is one of those areas
where we tend to engage in consultancy
work
and we do assist um service departments
to review areas
it's it's part of i suppose
collaboration and cooperation we don't
like to just be seen as the nasty orders
that comes in and tells you
you're doing something wrong so we like
to i suppose
build a positive relationship with the
audit client and if they ask for a bit
of work
further down the line if we undertake an
audit that they're more likely to
to to cooperate so it's it's a space
it's a mutual mutual thing in a way we
will
undertake some work of consultancy
nature just to build that relationship
and say
you know it's not all about audit work
and key financials and things like that
so we like to try and be supportive if
if resources allow for that
allow for that then we will want to take
that work
okay thank you
thank you uh councillor stanley
thank you chairman um just relating to
what i've said earlier on the
health and safety side of the audit uh
things have changed drastically with the
new
officers now in the
employment of rdc um
with those working from home what
health and safety have we altered
in the audit to to in light of
the employment of these new officers
well we haven't necessarily undertaken
any audio work in relation to health for
safety
and remote working so um
i mean i mean i think jim and naomi can
probably comment on what the
organization is doing
in terms of people working from home and
accounts of police on that but
we have not already did the arrangements
so um
i will have to um defer to my my
colleagues see if they can provide some
answers
um i i suppose the the answer
maybe to your question is that health
and safety
is um obviously one of our corporate
risks and is something that is
potentially on the plan for next year
where
where there is a change in the ways of
working obviously there is
potentially increased risk um associated
with that and i think that's something
that as part of the internal audit they
would
scope any changes in working practices
and risks associated with that and they
could perhaps test some of that
um as part of the health and safety
audit um
that's on the plan for next year um
so i don't really want to sort of
preempt or pass judgement on the
effectiveness of
of any controls that are in place but it
certainly is something that has been
discussed in his
leadership team and you know health and
safety officer and
hr are aware that there is potential
changes and
and risks associated with changes to
working practices
um but i would just yes advise that
that's something we'd probably look at
as part of the scope of the audit that's
planned for next year
in relation to what i was thinking was
that
um obviously officers now will have to
travel from home
to wherever they need to go to whether
it is the council offices to get
information or
whatever the case is and in the future
um
they will they will begin to travel a
lot more
uh in their vehicles and that they're no
longer
in a office if you like that
that they can work from for eight hours
or whatever the case is
and this is where the risk will be i
think will be greater
because of of that yes
okay well i'm not sure what the council
is necessarily
liable or comfortable for um employees
as
they're going to and from wherever i'm
not health and safety expert so i i
suppose what i'm saying is that
yeah there is some changes in working
practices but i think we would need to
assess the risks associated with that
and
and and review the procedures in place
for that but um
uh yeah i'm not i don't really want to
pass comment before that work's been
undertaken
no i mean we we could scope the audio
accordingly
naomi
i think that we we need to identify that
as a
quite a high risk now um
because we would in obviously there'll
be
uh the officers would be insured um
but as it stands at the moment are they
of the same do they have the same cover
as as they would do if they was at off
council offices as
where they are now in their own homes
okay thank you you've noticed your
comments thank you cancer stanley
naomi i just wanted to ask is have
have the staff been assessed in their
home invites for their seating
arrangements when working at their
computer
because i know a lot of companies have
um have had a look at this for
you know making sure that their posture
is correct they've got the right working
seats and desks and that and i wondered
whether ours had um our stafford
had had that opportunity
um thank you council butcher again i'm
i'm probably not the the best
person to advise but i am certainly
aware that we have um
reissued or made available the um sort
of
self-assessment guides and manuals about
working
um from home to make sure that people
can self-assess
um if they have any specific risks or
needs
when working from home and we have
encouraged staff if they've got any
particular concerns
um or any particular needs that they um
uh yeah i've been in contact with our
health and safety officer in hr
departments and certainly we have
delivered
um quite a lot of equipment from the
office to people's homes to enable them
to work in um
in a safe and comfortable environment so
it is something that's certainly been on
leadership's teams agenda and we have
made every effort to make sure that um
yeah people can work safely from home
oh thank you naomi for that i just
wanted to check because i know
a lot of companies do do that and i
wanted to make sure that we
we had um enabled them to self-assess to
ensure that they
say their posture is right they're not
going to give themselves back
difficulties in the future
thank you
all right any further questions can't
see anybody oh
yes councillor sure thank you chairman
surely all this discussion comes under
risk assessment um which will be carried
out
at the appropriate times just an
observation
but yeah i think i don't know if mike
wants to comment but uh yeah i would
just agree
yeah i think as part of the audit remit
for all of the work we do yeah
at the start we skype what you know what
are the risks and then we would
sort of judge the work program
accordingly to that so yeah i just would
concur with what you said thank you
yes
right i see no further questions
so at paragraph 9
1 on page 7.5 there is one
recommendation which i will move from
the chair
that the proposed audit plan and charter
for 2021 22 be approved
do i have a second of please happy to
second that uh chairman
thank you councillor merrick
right please unmute yourself now and
tell me if you're not able to use the
electronic hand icon and raise your hand
manually so it can be counted
if anyone would like a recorded vote to
be taken please click on the raise hand
icon once
chairman no one's indicating
thank you
so there is no recorded vote so voting
will be done by an electronic show of
hands
all those in favor of the
recommendations please click on the
raise hand icon once
[ __ ] chairman that's fine
all right thank you very much everybody
that's carried
um that concludes the meeting thank you
everybody for attending
and have a good evening thank you truman
thank you very much chairman thank you
good chairman